[MUSIC PLAYING]
What did you think
of the data set?
Yeah, it's very wordy.
I was like, what am I
going to do with this?
I mean, I thought of something.
It's totally-- not
too much analysis.
It's kind of like, there's
some interesting words here,
let's just feature some words.
OK.
Yeah.
Do you want to see it?
I do want to see.
I want--
OK.
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm also curious if
we did the same thing.
Yeah.
I approach this like, let's
just get a bunch of words,
and show me some long [BLEEP]
words and some short [BLEEP]
words and give me
some definitions.
It's really fun because I
was able to find a package.
Wait, what?
A different package
that defines words.
It's called dictionaRy
with a capital R somewhere,
dictionaRy define.
I was like, that
was kind of sweet.
And you know what they do?
They actually have--
they use an API.
Like they hid an API somewhere.
OK.
And they're able to get audio
as well, like audio links.
So I thought, let's put
some audio in this table.
This table can speak to you.
Tables always speak to
me, but this will actually
speak to you.
OK.
So what I want to do is
get the types of words--
and these are long
intro words, basically.
I'm sometimes impressed
with very long words like--
Well, yeah, because how
do you pronounce them?
--about 15 letters and so on.
Yeah, and there's some words
I don't know how to pronounce.
I would like to see
them pronounced.
So this is actually quite nice.
So what I'm doing here is this
will show me random words.
It'll just pick from
those giant word lists
from those crossword puzzles and
give me like five long words,
give me five short
words, define them.
It's almost like Word
of the Day times five.
Well, times 10, actually.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it's good.
So what I did was like--
OK, so I got the--
as it did before, in
the last table battle,
I just sourced all the
reading of the tables.
I basically just ignored
all the columns, except--
this is so bad for TidyTuesday,
like ignore everything
except for one column.
Basically I just
got all the words,
and then I did some
cleanup, as I often do,
made everything lowercase,
made it all nice,
sorted the long words
from the short words.
And then I hit this
API which was given
to you by this dictionaRy.
OK.
I just searched for like a
cramp package that would be--
offered me some definitions.
And this is like a
three-star package.
It deserves more
than three stars.
So if you see a dictionaRy
around, give it a star.
Give it more stars.
Yeah.
Yeah, it does a lot.
This is some work here.
Yeah.
So I had to do a heck
of a lot of stuff
because sometimes it'd
just be like weird outputs,
so I had to do some
pretty wild stuff
to make it work, all this stuff.
So ignore this.
This is this basically
just trying to fish
out one pronunciation,
[? like phonetic ?]
pronunciation.
I load possibly a list
which may be empty.
So I had to go through all this.
And then finally, I
get the audio link,
and here's a cool thing.
So I finally get to my gt table.
OK, another thing I noticed--
the API hits doesn't
always give you a lot.
Sometimes words
[? don't get ?] defined.
So basically what I
do is I get 40 words,
and then I score
them in terms of what
it offers in terms of metadata.
That's all this stuff.
And then I sort them and just
get the cream of the crop,
as it were.
I basically descend by
the score, slice the head,
and then I get words
with some stuff to them.
It has some metadata
like the pronunciation.
I did the same thing as last
time I made columns with--
I defined the widths.
Here's the really cool thing.
You can, in most
browsers-- well, all
browsers circa a long time,
you could now use an audio tag.
And you just provide
the URL, which
is what dictionaRy,
that R package, does.
And you just wrap the
URL inside these tags.
And then you get--
it's playable.
You get this little audio
player in your freaking table.
OK.
So I can show you this.
And there's some cases
where you don't have audio,
so I can do this basically.
Take a look.
OK.
Eventually it gets to the end.
I'll show you this table,
or this function, really.
Show me words.
I can choose from
times or big_dave.
So here we go with times.
It takes a few seconds
because it's doing
some querying, some API stuff.
OK.
Here we go.
What?
Here's a selection of words,
both long and short, and yeah,
so it's sorted by long
words, short words.
And here, check it out.
Right here, this is
where you get audio.
You see sometimes you
don't get the audio?
Yeah.
It's disappointing.
Sometimes you just--
it's just bad luck.
OK, hopefully this works.
We'll hear some beans.
Beans.
You hear that?
Nice.
OK.
Awesome, awesome.
Steel.
OK, I know these words.
I'm going to do this again.
This is like rolling
the dice one more time.
Maybe big_dave will provide.
We got some.
We got some hits.
Disproportion-- here we go.
Disproportion.
Nice, well-read.
Degeneration.
Same person.
Same person this time.
Proportionate.
Yeah.
Oh, we've got a
long-word aficionado.
Oh, did you know that
drake is a male duck?
Drake.
I don't know that I knew that.
What is fichu?
Fichu?
Fichu.
Oh, wow.
It's a scarf.
Now I know.
OK.
Patrol-- how do they
pronounce patrol?
Patrol.
Yeah.
They've got some
Britishisms going on.
But yeah, this is
the final word.
That's amazing.
Yeah, this is what I did.
I didn't-- this is
my little twist,
adding this little audio thing.
This could be a Shiny app.
Yeah.
It could be in a Shiny app.
I think.
For Word a Day.
Oh, yeah, of course.
Yeah, because its function.
And it just produces a table.
It's got a height which I think
I control because what I did
is I also set the height,
not so easy to do in a table
if you have overflow,
so you have to set it
a bit beyond what you expect.
There's probably a way to really
fix it with overflow and stuff,
but I always can't
figure it out.
And like 10 [? overflow ?]
searches later, I just give up.
But I did this, line height and
then max height then height.
And then maybe this
does something.
Maybe it's actually why that--
I don't know.
Anyways, this date
will work for this.
That's what I
feel about overflow.
I use it sometimes, and I
think it fixes the problem,
but I'm not confident.
Yeah.
Yeah, you really got to
experiment in the DevTools.
So I add a bunch of CSS.
And again, I'll just
review this one more time.
If you do that, it's
really vitally important
that you set the ID on the
table, just right here in gt.
And then once you do that-- the
reason why you would do that
is because, well, say
you have some documents
with a bunch of tables on it.
You just want to set
[? the AD. ?] Typically
you just want to set the
CSS for the one table
you're focusing on and
not for every other table.
So it just protects
against multiple tables.
Oh.
Yeah.
So if you didn't have this,
it would just be like--
maybe that's good,
maybe that's bad.
But I just think it's bad.
Yeah.
So these are my functions.
So I'm just proving that you
can make tables from functions,
and it's not that bad.
So, like you,
I was very much--
we're not getting tables
with data or numbers.
There's data, but so far
we've had [? NAs ?] and then
text data.
So what I thought I
would do is play around
a little bit with tidytext from
Julia Silge and Dave Robinson.
Excellent idea.
So like you're going to get
sentiment for these words.
That's exactly what I did.
You [? do relevant-- ?]
yeah, nice.
Nice.
So I was like, well, what's
a good way to group things
that's not too large?
Like I don't want
this massive table.
So I was like, OK, do I want
to do the clue or the answer?
And I went with the
answer because I
didn't want to strip
out all of the numbers.
And I just didn't--
and then also does the answer--
if you're using the
clue, I was like,
I don't know if that gives you a
sentiment because the clues are
often placed on words.
Yeah, there was that.
They're really-- I
don't think you ever get
into these puzzles.
I know a lot of people that do.
But wow, it takes a
while to get into.
These are tough clues.
Yeah.
Yeah, some of these are hard.
So I was like--
I played around
with it a little,
got to use a little lubridate,
which is always fun.
So converting the numeric,
I just wanted the month.
And then I essentially
went through--
I did have some NA dates,
so I just dropped those.
I'm definitely a "just
get rid of the NA values"
default. Sorry to
everyone out there
who does not believe in that.
No, that's a good idea.
And then I-- what did I do?
Yeah, so I did that.
And then I kind of played
around with things.
And I just used-- so Julia and
Dave recommend three libraries,
and this is from tidytext.
So I just went with one of
them, and I did a little join
and got a nice
little-- actually,
let's run some of this.
Let's see what we get.
Running a whole bunch of
stuff we don't need to run,
and that's fine.
So I didn't know what big_dave,
but I [? read ?] it in.
And then I just worked
with The Times' data.
You could do all of
them if you wanted.
But basically I got the month,
the word, the sentiment,
and then the count, the number
of times that it appeared.
So I was like, oh,
OK, what I could
do is I can group by
month, and then this
combines all the years.
And then I was
like, I could take
the number-one negative word
and the number-one positive word
for each month.
See if times get seasonal
affective disorder or something
like that.
Winter months,
everything's like--
We get all
negative in January.
So I ended up using--
I was thinking about
how I wanted to do this.
I arranged it, and then
I just did a slice max.
Nice.
And then-- oh, yeah,
here's the basic table.
So you've got your month, your
word, and then your sentiment.
And so I thought that was kind
of fun, and then I was like,
let's make it look
a little nicer.
So I went for a black and
white theme, like a newspaper.
That's nice.
Thank you.
What font is that?
This is Libre--
Libre Baskerville.
Yeah, I was thinking of
using Baskerville, too.
It seems like such a
great writerly font.
Yeah.
So The New York Times, it
turns out, uses Georgia,
and Georgia is not
on Google Fonts.
I think I have
Georgia, but I was
like, we'll do Google Fonts
so it's replicable for anybody
at home doing this.
Yeah, Baskerville's
a total classic.
I'm glad there's a
free version of that.
Yeah, so did that,
pretty happy with it.
I couldn't get--
like it bothers me
that this space is
bigger than this space.
And so I spent some time
moving things around,
and just couldn't get
it where I wanted it.
It's tough because it
doesn't center nicely.
Then everything gets crowded.
It gets too thin.
I don't know, its--
Yeah, it was rough.
I made it work.
I thought it was interesting.
How did I-- what's the
best way to present things?
Because there were a
lot of ties, right?
So February has multiple ties
for its most positive words.
And then I think
there's something here
around the spread.
So almost always you
see your negative word.
There's always a clear
negative winner and then
a spread of positive winners.
There's never really-- like
June, abolish and elite.
There we go, done deal.
But there's-- oh, OK August,
you see a lot more negative.
I don't know what's
happening in August.
People are not as happy
in August, I guess.
Yeah, that's an angry month.
Right?
That's what I'm seeing.
Lots of anger.
You're either idle
or you're irate, irate.
You're going to sack something.
Loose, too.
Sue.
You get litigious, too.
Oh my God.
Yeah, September
starts to balance out.
October, a little more
negative than positive.
So I thought this was--
and then I've got my little
source notes in here.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I did not use--
That was fantastic
--a [? blowing ?]
lowering the line.
I thought of it later,
and I was like, it's OK.
It's OK.
But I think, if
I were to redo this
or if I were to keep
working on this,
I was really curious
about doing something
where, instead of just
looking at the top,
it kind of did a full
sum of all the negatives,
and then a full sum
of all the positives,
and then it gave you a
positivity proportion.
So if it was--
let's take blue and orange.
If it's more positive,
it's more blue,
and it would somehow color--
That would be interesting,
like the months themselves,
Yeah.
So you could look at
January and be like, oh,
that's really orange,
it's a really angry month,
whereas February is blue, and
you could see how that swings.
So that, to me, was like-- that
would be a really interesting
programmatic next step.
And then maybe give a sample of
the most negative words or most
positive.
Those are good ideas.
I'm surprised
there's no neutral.
I guess that's just the way.
these--
So it's the sentiment
library that I used.
Oh, I see.
So this doesn't have
that, I guess, right?
Yeah.
So this sentiment library--
and tidytext, Mining with
R-- it's a great book.
That goes into all of
the things that you
need to think about when
you do this kind of work,
but it is just--
I think that it is
just positive or--
that's it.
It's a very dichotomous--
Yeah, that's right.
Speaking of tables, I love
what you did with doing away
with the column labels.
It's totally not needed.
It's obvious what's
going on here.
And you just used
the group labels to--
Yeah.
--organize everything.
I did that.
That was-- Let me go in here.
I just dropped them by
putting them in these blanks.
Oh, perfect.
That's good because it
leaves space, which is nice.
Yeah.
Yeah, so you get a
little space here.
And then I thought about,
oh, like decorative borders.
And I was like, no, it's
almost like a newspaper column.
Yeah.
That's what I'm seeing here.
That's the vibe I get, totally.